[Musique]
l'annnonce du jour les chéris c'est que
une chroniqueuse nous rejoint dans tpm
pays elle va démarrer la semaine
prochaine elle sera avec nous nous
estimons à votre avis ceux qui savent le
plan jeunes en juin dont je suis la
chroniqueuse qui rejoint tpm paix et
pour moi c'est un grand grand honneur de
l'avoir achevé le trailer ophélie winter
non pas là c'est pas elle abat mère
gérer la même nom miam
elle avait la chouette arlette chabot
vincent mcdoom et qu'est ce qui des
lourds
alex est ce qu'elle est déjà venu ici en
invité oui mais est-ce que c'est une
personne de la télévision oui jaune
alors ma part jamais alors c'est à dire
jeunes moins de 50 ans n'ont pas moins
de 30 ans mais pas alors ouais je laime
ramener oui catherine laborde non à la
prime abord très bonne réponse
d'isabelle m'en moque
carolina quand on embrasse quoi yen fort
catherine laborde va rejoindre l'équipe
de tpm ps va faire un essai pendant pro
démission il veut voir comment elles
sont avec nous tout ça elle était
tellement contente quand elle est venue
une fois ici on experte médias qui a dit
j'aimerais bien revenir moi voilà dès
qu'elle a dit khaled partez de tf1 je la
plus de soi même pour lui dire tu es la
bienvenue dans touche pas à mon poste
quand tu veux et je suis très heureux
d'accueillir catherine laroque avec
glaçons et qui va rejoindre l'équipe de
tmp est ce que vous êtes content mais
j'ai hâte de la voir en jeu trouble fête
dans l'émotion du prochain débat c'est
quelqu'un qui est déjà très bienveillant
qui a un regard différent donc on
n'avait pas dans l'équipe donc oui c'est
une bonne recrue
moi je suis perdant dites nous si vous
êtes content chez vous tiens on va voir
sondage est ce que c'est une bonne
recrue ou pas catherine laborde
oui non non il ya eu près sabbatique
mais j'ai peur qu'elle soit le chaumont
trop con si dur est un peu trouble
bisous nous avons laissé le mariage mais
elle est prise et notamment les livres
de catherine laborde qui sont
extrêmement surprenants et le puck bah
oui mais vous vous découvrirez une femme
de caractère qui a eu qui a un vécu
absolument incroyable et qui devra vous
surprendre d'imagés m6 dans l'émission
alors on avance à elle viendra donc la
semaine prochaine
on est très heureux regardez sur le
sondage twitter dites nous voilà moi je
suis fou d'elle
bonne idée à 68% voilà 63 beau bassin on
va arrêter
[Rires]
en tout cas c'est une bonne idée pour la
majorité des gens et c'est très rare
parce que c'est vrai que vous êtes assez
dur quand on fait rentrer de nouvelles
personnes
voilà vous essayez c'est pas c'est une
place de moins risqué parce qu'on y en a
un qui revient d'un quasi non alors lui
les sociétés gardent tout le monde sait
déjà qu'on est 120 c'est vrai c'est vrai
mais parce que j'aime
voilà la révélation du jour oui c'est un
jour poser une question oui mais est-ce
que nettement quand ophélie winter est
venu vous ça vous a pas vous avez pas
pensé ou pas vous avez mentionné je vous
dise à vérifier winter a de grandes
chances de rejoindre touche pas moi si
j'ai vu l'émission j'aurais vu à 6 eh
ben vous avez reçu 10 il a dans le lieu
proposé à la cloche elle a dit oui au
fait des a dit oui
[Applaudissements]